everyone nowadays believes in education
we train kids to do maths we teach
pilots how to learn planes and surgeons
how to operate on our brains but there's
one area where we don't seem to believe
in education at all we just leave people
to figure it out themselves life itself
there's an odd silence in education when
it comes to the truly big questions who
should we get together with how can you
manage your relationship what career are
you suited to what's money for how can
we manage anxiety and what do we do with
regret and shame what do we do about
illness and aging how do we deal with
our families here there is very
strangely often no one to turn to
nowhere to go
so stress accumulates and disasters
occur
we wanted a place to help with this
stuff so we built this school of life an
open-minded rigorous on ideological
organization devoted to helping you deal
with the important things that you are
never taught at school relationships
careers anxieties and emotions we have
physical homes across the world in
London Paris Antwerp Amsterdam Istanbul
Melbourne Rio and here online we'll be
posting new films every week that
address the great questions we don't
have to keep making the same mistakes
there are things to be learnt while
there's still time